rendez compte on en est du débat quand
vous avez quelqu'un qui postent un
simple tweet pour dire je suis opposé à
toute forme de violence elle se fait
lyncher à son tour et elle se fait
harceler sur les réseaux sociaux est
menacé parce que j'ai eu les réponses
qu'ils étaient amants d'une dent degré
de violence visant journée origin qui a
juste dit qu'elle n'acceptait pas les
violences qui est ce qui est
complètement honteux
madame l'ami je trouve votre commentaire
très limite qui fracasse des citoyens
français ce sont la police madame l'ami
les casseurs sont des policiers
voulaient faire un commentaire de pc
tout en votre honneur ce que je
comprends je me mouille mais pas trop
décevant ce que vivent les fics
aujourd'hui c'est les conséquences de la
colère et la haine qu'ils ont semé
effectivement c'est pas bien mais pas
incompréhensible
qu'est ce que vous répondez canton d'is
et c'est juste parce qu'il n'ya rien n'y
a rien jamais justifier les gens ce papa
c'est un principe de base on dit pour
les violences conjugales et les
violences à l'égard des femmes mais on
dit pour n'importe quelle violence le
harcèlement scolaire et a rien qui
justifie tabassé un policier à 5 y a
rien qui justifie tabassé en producteur
de musique qui va ce travail a rien qui
justifie pluie mais ce que je lance
jamais assez simple c'est inaudible
aujourd'hui à 65 % des français qui
soutiennent la police mais le reste ne
la soutient pas mais je sais que je sais
que c'est difficile et je sais que mais
comme disait nietzsche l'art de la
nuance est difficile et malheur à ceux
qui prônent y prône une parole nuancé
mais je crois que c'est justement parce
qu'on est dans un débat caricatural et
d'affrontements et de la tâche qu'il
faut aussi essayer de temps en temps par
un peu de recul et est d'essayer de
porter la voix de la raison en tout cas
j'essaye est-ce que vous merci on peut
pas non merci merci à tous bah oui il
est 21 ans est très vite à demain non
c'est pour savoir est-ce que gouvernance
est ce qu'on la clé pour changer tout ça
avec vos lois dites les violences
répond le départ était de dire des
conneries
j'avais fait plus de 30 ans ouais c'est
vrai j'avais été dans les commissariats
le gouvernement fait tout ce qui est en
son pouvoir mais le gouvernement peut
pas tout tout seul il faut que la
société soit unie et qu'on essaie comme
ça être une échelle je vais reprendre 50
ça on ne peut pas être uniforme de les
gens ils ont vu ce qui s'est passé ou
des premières manifestations des jeunes
les gens ils ont vu qu'elle castaner
envoyé la police pour taper sa désunis
là on fait une manif pourquoi parce
qu'on veut pas filmer la police les gens
ils sont filmés dans la rue comprend des
radars on est filmé quand on se gare en
stationnement aime et on n'hésite à tan
tan et déterminé vidéo-verbalisation les
violences vous parler des violences
faites aux femmes
vous dites j'irais là dit elle ont peur
des femmes pourquoi elles ont peur parce
qu'elles vont porter plainte une fois
elles rentrent s ont dérouillé elles
vont porter plainte deux fois est rentré
ce sont des rouliers trois fois elles
sont débrouillés elles vont plus c'est à
vous de changer ça apparaît sur les
violences policières savons peut changer
ça je vais pousser pas de venir là que
je fais depuis que j'ai la chance de me
battre je les fais avant que ce soit
ensuite on vous parle sur les plateaux
télé avant que ce soit à payer j'ai
geneva quand on était 10 avec nos
petites pancartes on le faisait et moi
je me bats justement pour que maintenant
les policiers soient mieux formés
maintenant il ya 120 heures de formation
pour les policiers et leur donner les
moyens plus des formations continues
on leur donne les fonctions de témoigner
en plus le 25 novembre avec les
directeurs de la police et la
gendarmerie pour former et équiper les
policiers avec des grilles d'évaluation
de joe danger pour que jamais une femme
ne repart sans solution d'un
commissariat
et c'est pour ça qu'on a créé cette
plate forme et je termine une violence
point gouv.fr il ya des policiers
vingt quatre heures sur vingt quatre et
des gendarmes qui répondent aux femmes
qui les sauve des violences dans
lesquelles elles sont et cette
plateforme
elle est extrêmement importante parce
qu'elle évite de se rendre dans un
commissariat donc on fait des choses des
choses n'avancent pas assez vite je suis
d'accord avec vous mais on fait pas rien
des choix d'agir si la police de roanne